a drawn out and tough Israeli operation
against Palestinian Hamas Fighters
Israel's military says it's fully
regained control of towns on the
southern border with Gaza and it's ready
for its next phase in the war some of
the Hamas Fighters were able to evade
Israeli Security Forces for nearly 3
days while holding a number of Israeli
captives in the southern
towns all this as Hamas Rockets continue
to be fired from Gaza into Israel
causing destruction to infrastructure
including a police station in
stot Israel is threatening further
military action in Gaza 300,000 Israeli
reservists have been called and are on
standby with reinforcements being sent
to Southern Israel and now
this I have ordered a Complete Siege on
the Gaza Strip there will be no
electricity no food no fuel everything
is closed we are fighting Human animals
and we act accordingly
more than half of the towns on the
southern border have been
evacuated Israel's cabinet invoked
article 40 El if on Sunday giving
effectively the Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and the defense minister the
ability to make war decisions without
consulting the cabinet every time the
last time that was used was for the
October 6th
war on Monday far away areas from Gaza
like Tel Aviv Jerusalem and an Al
Israeli settlement in occupied West Bank
were targeted by Hamas
[Music]
rockets and in Northern Israel the
military says it has killed fighters who
attempted to infiltrate from Lebanon
further complicating the war sakat AL
jaaz West Jerusalem